buffett's calls every day a coin flip
when it comes down to nuclear weapons
uh he had no answers but plenty of
caution about the threat and impact of
nuclear weapons saying that every day is
a living
with flipping a coin the world is
flipping a coin every day whether people
who can literally destroy the planet as
we know it all as we know it and we'll
do it buffett said to an audience a
berkshire hathaway shareholder saturday
unfortunately the majority prop the
major problem is that people who have
large stocks of nuclear weapons and
icbms unfortunately the major problem is
the people that own it
they talk about using tactical nuclear
weapons if someone is willing to kill
hundreds of thousands of people with
tactical nuclear weapons
why would they stop there he added it's
very very dangerous world it's a very
very dangerous world the question
submitted by the shareholder asked about
the impact of nuclear weapons on
berkshire's operations and outlook the
company maintains a number of insurance
operations and a nuclear attack would
severely impact the company's operations
as a result do you think we're
closer maybe let me ask a question this
way when's the last time we had a
nuclear wha what was the timeline
when a truman dropped the uh hiroshima
yeah what's the exact date what's the
exact date i'm curious
um it's november 45 is it i'm thinking
it's um
when did strap
do you see the date here's a question
for you are we
more likely
it's august 6th and august 9th 1914 45
which is what that's about 80 years 75
77 years right
are we closer to
that
nuclear
uh
bomb being dropped or
is it gonna happen in the next 77 years
meaning do you know what i'm asking like
is it going to be like yeah probably the
next 67 years someone's going to drop a
nuclear bomb
do you see that happening
about the western you know the declaring
war against you know ukraine and western
uh
let me see if we have that story here
yeah there it goes it's page three and
of course we're gonna have somebody next
week peter pry that we're gonna get into
that a little bit deeper because that's
a specialty but putin says to officially
declare war on ukraine western officials
say
the declaration is expected to be uh
made on may 9th when russia marks
victory day over the nazi germany 1940
and then he's talking about nuclear so
let me see go to the article about
nuclear he said something about using
nuclear if necessary they would use it
so
do you think it's that scary like do you
wake up yourself every day worried about
a nuclear war i'll tell you i think
clearly that what we should be worried
about at this point is cyber warfare and
bio warfare that's that's what's
pervasive and what's that's going on in
the atmosphere today i mean look it's
not even close russia and u.s by far and
away have the most nuclear weapons in
the world it's not even close how many
thousands does russia have and how many
thousands of us have and then the next
is like china and france with like a
couple hundred it's not even close
what was what was you you asked why are
we closer to nuclear war 77 years ago or
in 77 years from now clearly in the past
i mean all our parents for the most part
that grew up in the 50s and 60s
they used to have to do fire drills
under their desk in case there was a
nuclear war during the cold war with
russia there almost was you know correct
that's why it was where this club with
cuba cuban missile prices may happen all
that
so
it's a lot of it is nuclear nuclear i
think i figured it's like almost like
ingrained in us like holy [ __ ] holy [ __ ]
but that isn't the biggest concern
at least as an american i mean
this puts another spin onto this topic
if you're in europe
you know to bring up the whole nato
topic why do you think the swedens of
the world or the norways of the world or
these types of countries are actually
thinking holy [ __ ] like you know why is
it why is the ukraine thing happening
because you are that close to russia
they are on your doorstep
u.s this is one of the beautiful things
about being in the united states being
the greatest country in the world
we don't have to worry about canada
attacking us we don't worry about mexico
attacking us maybe a caravan of migrants
coming into the country but we don't
have to worry about russia and putin on
your doorstep or even a north korea you
know on your uh southeast border getting
crazy so this is the luxury of being the
united states of america so as far as
nuclear warfare being in america
being a major concern that's not a major
concern of mine so i think there's two
scenarios where we have a nuclear bomb
go off uh one is
countries countries get nukes
to build a wall of deterrence right you
have a nuke no one's going to attack you
because you haven't it's not too the
best no
right it's a great insurance policy um
so in one scenario some loose fish fish
fish fish style material whatever it is
gets in the hands of a terrorist and
they plant a dirty bomb somewhere that
could happen i don't i don't think
that's beyond the realm of possibility
in our lifetime
to the extent of the damage who knows um
we underestimate terrorists all the time
however um the other one is if putin
gets backed into a corner i don't i
wouldn't put it past this guy
if he thinks his life is over
or his power is done
to go out with a bang i don't think it's
beyond his his uh ability or his
rationale do you agree well to matt's
point
the the
people always love to talk out of both
sides of their mouth right they say
vladimir's putin he's crazy he's got
cancer he's losing his mind he's an evil
warmonger and at the same time they say
no he'll never use nuclear weapons it's
not an option won't happen impossible
and and let's not forget that they have
the ability of using tactical nukes not
massive mother of all bombs 5500 ton you
know nuclear weapons they can use
tactical nukes and i think we we just
we're going to send over 33 billion
dollars in in military aid to ukraine
right and you can see what we've
provided already right we provided 5 500
javelin missiles which is one-third of
our stockpile if we continue to provide
the ukrainians with weapon system after
weapon system after weapon system and
intelligence youth it's a match point
you think he won't be backed into a
corner and say all right i'm done with
this no more
you've pushed me to the brink and he'll
use i i do not think in any manner are
tactical nukes out of the question on
the homeland i doubt it right like we
would rain hellfire
we we would
it's mutually assured destruction but
but to use it on ukraine no i don't
think that's out of the question in any
realm at all i don't think it's out of
the question for him to launch one of us
on his way down either honestly i mean
people say oh no no he would never do
that he's not suicidal what if he's
about to die you know or if he's about
to be dethroned or about to be
assassinated
right do we have are his are the people
who work at the russian nuclear silos
loyalists or are they scared for their
life too that's what it comes down to if
i'm an intelligence officer in the
united states i am trying to infiltrate
the people who work at the damn silos
and say if vlad launches don't press the
button you know what i mean whatever you
want a billion dollars come to the state
don't press that damn button that's
that's that's how it looks to me so if
you like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right here
[Music]